good news for home buyers to start the
new year Las Vegas realtors association
reports housing prices are back to where
they were a year ago Madison Kimbrough
spoke with the association and a recent
home buyer she joins us from the
southwest Valley tonight with more
if it seems like new housing
developments are popping up everywhere
you'd be right like this one your
Spanish Trail and according to the Las
Vegas Realtor Association the market is
more balanced now which means if you're
looking to buy a home prices are more
affordable
at the time the pickings were so slim
and so it was I'd have an offer on a
house but by the time my offer was
reviewed there were 30 other offers Mia
Browning just bought her home in 2022 in
the Aliante area of North Las Vegas at
the time it seemed like she and the rest
of the valley were making high offers on
homes as inventory was scarce fast
forward to now and home prices are
dropping and what was once considered a
seller's market is now more balanced Las
Vegas realtors association president Lee
Barrett explains in January of 2022
people were actually paying more for a
house than it was on the market for
anywhere between ten and fifty thousand
dollars well now the prices have dropped
according to lvr the median price of
existing single-family homes sold in
southern Nevada during December was 425
thousand dollars that's down 1.4 percent
from November and matches the median
price from December 2021 but for those
homeowners who just purchased property a
little bit of panic is set in knowing
that now they wouldn't be able to sell
their home and make a substantial profit
or break even I couldn't sell my home
now and buy something better even if I'm
making more money because my interest
rate is so much higher and then the
prices just keep dropping but while home
prices are decreasing making it easier
for a potential home buyer the price for
condos and town homes are actually up by
about two percent from December 2021
reporting near Hacienda and buffalo
Madison Kimbrough 8 news now as Madison
mentioned the price for condos and
Townhomes Townhomes rather still up that
median price being nearly 250 thousand
dollars